[Musik]
wir sind in der kolumbianischen provinz
chocó in einem abgelegenen dorf der ikk
delegierte abraham dorado überspielt
seine anspannung
wir geben die später etwas das sehr
schöne mütze ist sind wir nicht so groß
eine riskante flussreise steht bevor
mehrere bewaffnete gruppen stehen sich
hier gegenüber diese teil des flusses
wird von einer gruppe kontrolliert auf
der anderen seite sind zwei weitere es
ist wahnsinn auf diesem fluss triffst du
sie alle
in der letzten folge traf abraham doblo
verzweifelte casinos deren ernte
vernichtet wurde
[Musik]
ihk-präsident peter maurer besuchte
eines der schlimmsten gefängnisse afrika
aus und forderte menschlichere
haftbedingungen newcomerin stephanie l
absolvierte ihre ausbildung zu
delegierten und probte den ernstfall in
afghanistan lernten wir mit nadine den
alltag im orthopädie zentrum kennen
[Musik]
abraham und sein team sind in
alarmbereitschaft
nicht nur die fluss strömung ist
gefährlich die präsenz von kriminellen
banden belastet das team zusätzlich
wir können jeden moment angehalten
werden sie tragen uniformen und es ist
schwierig sie zu sehen wenn sie zeichen
machen müssen wir das sehen und anhalten
sonst denken sie wir fahren weiter und
schießen
abraham hofft den kommandanten einer
rebellengruppe treffen zu können um mit
ihm über die einhaltung des
internationalen völkerrechts zu sprechen
die präsenz unserer kamera macht das
unterfangen noch heikler und treibholz
ist ebenfalls eine gefahr
dann endlich nach langen stunden
erreichen wir das dorf in dem medien
acht geschützt verbringen können die
einwohner bleiben zurückhaltend zu
schlecht waren die erfahrungen die sie
mit fremden gemacht haben die menschen
hier leiden sehr unter den bewaffneten
gruppen
die regierung ist weit weg
es gibt kaum eine infrastruktur oder
eine gesundheitsversorgung hier leben
indios und afro kolumbianer in der
herberge zur guten erholung finden wir
eine unterkunft
abraham war es die betten zu alle wissen
es gibt viele ratten und andere
unangenehme bettgenossen mitarbeiterin
diana geht auf nummer sicher
ich suche nach schlangen aber haben
schläft lieber unter seinem eigenen
moskitonetz wie damals als delegierter
in afrika ich habe dieses moskitonetz in
der zentralafrikanischen republik schon
hundertmal aufgestellt gute auch dazu
übernachten
an schlaf ist vorerst nicht zu denken
[Musik]
die musik in kolumbien treibt dich in
den wahnsinn
man kann nie schlafen zu hause in gibt
wo dich deswegen am anfang ganz nervös
aber jetzt habe ich mich daran gewöhnt
[Musik]
in lausanne muss sich stéphanie elle von
ihrer familie verabschieden morgen
bricht sie zu ihrer ersten mission nach
israel auf
[Musik]
sie muss ist offen
nicht ohne stolz erzählt der funny der
familie und den freunden von der
ausbildung zu delegierten die sie
durchlaufen hat wir haben dann mit dem
gefängnis besuchen angefangen es war
intensiv aber cool ich werde gefangenen
besuchen schutzprogramme durchführen und
alles mögliche für die mutter ist der
fall es berufswahl keine überraschung
die familie ist immer schon weitgereist
stéphanie sie schon als junges mädchen
fasziniert gewesen von fremden ländern
und kulturen stephanie rice seit sie 17
ist damals wollte sie spanisch lernen
ich habe ihr einen sprachaufenthalt in
spanien vorgeschlagen aber sie sagte
nein ich gehe nach kuba damals war sie
16 einhalb nachher ging sie in die usa
nach portimao kolumbien und costa rica
brasilien brasilien das man nur ferien
wir sind es gewohnt abschied und
wiedersehen zu feiern ist der von ihr
stiefvater kennt ihre stärken und ihre
schwächen
[Musik]
stefan ist wie ein vogel immer nicht
einsperren darf sie ist glücklich wenn
sie im ausland ist das braucht sie sie
liebt es andere mentalitäten und völker
kennen zu lernen
das schlimmste für sie ist wenn man sie
zwingt im büro zu sitzen
sie hat einmal sechs monaten bei mir in
der firma gearbeitet
nun sie hat das gut gemacht weil sie
wusste es ist befristet bis spät in die
nacht feiert die familie ist der fall es
aufbruch in ein neues leben
[Musik]
wir sind in kabul der hauptstadt
afghanistans
die menschen hier sind gezeichnet vom
jahrzehntelangen krieg das ikk
orthopädie zentrum fast alle die hier
arbeiten sind ehemalige patienten
jeder muss sich eintragen aber die
meisten können weder lesen noch
schreiben sie behelfen sich mit einem
moor einem stempel mit namen
sitzungen gehören auch in diesem erdteil
zum alltag direktor 100 studien trifft
seine abteilungsleiter gibt es etwas
neues über das wir sprechen müssen haben
sie vorschläge oder kritik wir haben
eine fliegenplage wie kann man sie am
rhein fliegen hindern mit einem netz
hauptsache sie können nicht rein fliegen
was soll sich darum kümmern
dann macht sich nadine auf den weg zu
seinem ersten patienten seine prothese
muss dringend ersetzt werden
das modell trägt selber zwei
beinprothesen seine unterschenkel hat er
als 18-jähriger verloren als sie auf
eine landmine fuhr
afghanistan ist bis heute eines der am
stärksten mit minen verseuchten länder
der welt
hast du an john angerufen
er soll auch dabei sein kontakt wie geht
es dir sehr alt und kaputt
man kann sie nicht mehr benutzen ich
glaube vorher hatte er eine prothese von
uns dann ging er in ein anderes zentrum
und erhielt diese auch allah mohammad
ist ein minenopfer er ist auf eine mine
getreten in kandahar vor 25 jahren
bleibt die patientenkarte hineingehe
darüber und wir bringen sie
das orthopädie zentrum hat platz für 300
patienten horb taliban oder zivilperson
hier werden alle behandelt aller
mohamads alte prothese passt nicht mehr
darum trägt er acht socken übereinander
prothesen oder gehhilfen sind kostenlos
für alle
allah mohammad lebt in kabul und ist
arbeitslos eine neue prothese eröffnet
ihm neue perspektiven
[Musik]
ist diese prothese nur für ein jahr
nein die kann man zehn zwanzig jahre
benutzen bis jemand kaputt macht die
können wir auch reparieren und falls es
nötig ist können wir eine neue
herstellen
dann komme ich wieder
immer wenn etwas ist kommst du zu uns
immer wieder wird er nun in die
werkstatt bringen mit gips füllen und
einen negativ ab druck machen dann
müssen wir einige anpassungen machen
damit sie wirklich passt
[Musik]
in der kolumbianischen provinz chocó war
die nacht brach am blauen brief sein
team denn der rebellenkommandant hat
ihnen ein abgelegenes dorf bestellt es
sind indigene gemeinschaften indios wir
treffen sie um zu erfahren wie sie mit
den rebellen leben
es ist sehr wichtig personen in dem
rebellenkommandanten zu treffen
wir sprechen mit ihm über unsere
bedenken um manni teeren 8 es geht um
die sicherheit und akzeptanz unseres
teams hauptsächlich aber geht es um den
sogenannten schutz dialog wir sprechen
mit ihnen über vorfälle in der
vergangenheit
wenn jemand verschwunden ist ein angriff
stattgefunden hat minderjährige
rekrutiert wurden oder wenn minen
eingesetzt werden
sie benutzten minen das müssen wir
ansprechen
so findet das humanitäre völkerrecht im
alltag anwendung
das team nimmt abschied von den
einheimischen
[Musik]
der ausgang dieser mission ist ungewiss
die ln rebellen deren kommandant wir
treffen wollen sind marxistisch
orientierte geringes nur zwei monate vor
unserem dreh haben sie zwei deutschland
führt nun aber vorher geht es die
strömung und die auflaufenden
kriminellen banden heil zu überstehen
es ist sicher dass sich die rebellen
jetzt in diesem gebiet aufhalten
deshalb ist es wichtig nicht aufzufallen
von hier an hat die ln die nationale
befreiungsarmee das sagen
zwar hat abraham die ankunft angekündigt
aber sicherheit ist nicht garantiert
sie sind bewaffnet und man kann nie
wissen wie sie reagieren
der kommandant weiß wer wir sind
aber wir wissen nicht ob seine
untergebenen das ika ärger auch kennen
deshalb versuchen wir so unauffällig wie
möglich zu sein
dann muss unser reporter die kamera
abschalten
der kommandant will unter keinen
umständen gefilmt werden
[Musik]
wir fliegen von kinshasa nach goma aus
sicherheitsgründen in der ikk eigenen
maschine präsident peter maurer hat
keine bedenken
die base das sicherheitsdispositiv
michael krause weiß dass man seriös
mitarbeiterinnen die dies positiv
respektieren und die welt so dass
integration des besuchen jeden tag wenn
die luftige dass sie die entsprechende
vorsichtsmaßnahmen ergriffen
[Musik]
die machen dann sind mir sorgen wenn man
doch ähnliche regionen der sommer ist
[Musik]
coma eine gegend in der seit 20 jahren
erbittert gekämpft wird trotz
fruchtbarer böden und reicher
bodenschätze eben die menschen in
bitterer armut
erst kamen die flüchtlinge aus ruanda
dann vertriebene aus dem eigenen land
während unserer dreharbeiten macht die
miliz m23 die gegend unsicher
rund 200.000 vertriebene sind hier
gestrandet
peter maurer beginnt das kinderheim don
bosco hier leben die jüngsten opfer des
krieges weisen vertriebene und ehemalige
kindersoldaten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir wünschen uns dass alle kinder zur
schule gehen können ohne von bewaffneten
gewinne kredit zu stellen dass unsere
mitte auf den markt gehen können viele
verletzte werden dass betriebene einige
dörfer zurück kriegen können
[Applaus]
was rührend aussieht ist ein panorama
des elends therapie juli leitet das heim
seit 40 jahren
er ist gebürtiger italiener
sophie laufer
wie kommst du kommst aus
pietro juli ist so etwas wie eine
legende hier
er hat fast sein ganzes leben im kongo
verbracht auf die interne schule ist er
stolz und sie liegt ihm am herzen
er weiß bildung gibt den kindern eine
perspektive
[Musik]
tel aviv nach jerusalem die zweitgrößte
stadt israels
sie ist die neue heimat von stéphanie lr
für ein jahr
heute hat die 28 jährige ihren ersten
arbeitstag
am eingang habe ich eine stechuhr
gesehen die aufzeichnet wann man kommt
und wann man geht es ist besser eines
der wichtigsten jüdischen feste und die
meisten angestellten sind in den ferien
von philips der islamischen
wissenschaften und hebräische geschichte
studiert hat erklärt stefanie wie
gefangenen besucher gemacht werden
kennen die leute im gefängnis das edeka
oder erklärst du ihnen jeweils wer wir
sind und was wir machen wie gut den
gefangenen die meisten menschen aus der
westbank also die palästinenser haben
einen angehörigen im gefängnis sie
kennen zumeist unserer familien
besuchsprogramm und dadurch auch das ikk
aber die wenigsten wissen mehr über uns
du musst nicht stundenlang erklären sag
einfach wir besuchen gefängnis
kontrollieren die haftbedingungen
wir wollen mit euch sprechen und sehen
ob alles in ordnung ist
stefanie hat respekt vor ihrer neuen
aufgabe
was mir momentan am meisten sorgen macht
ist nicht der umgang mit den offiziellen
da fühle ich mich ziemlich sicher was
mir angst macht ist dass ich wichtige
informationen verpasse weil ich das
arabisch der gefangenen nicht verstehe
in diesem job kommt es häufig vor dass
man denkt ich kann nichts bewirken
aber es sind die kleinen augenblicke die
zählen solche in denen man einfach da
ist für menschen in extremsituationen im
allgemeinen läuft es gut
doch holz scheint alles ziemlich klar
das hast du toll gemacht mit der
einführung
ich habe die nase voll ich möchte jetzt
endlich anfangen
büroarbeit gehört hier dazu und nicht zu
knapp
[Musik]
im orthopädie zentrum in kabul werden
prothesen von hand gefertigt fast alle
angestellten sind auch betroffene das
ikk gibt ihnen arbeit in diesem land in
dem jeder zweite nicht behinderte ohne
beschäftigung ist jedes jahr fertigen
wir 4000 prothesen an
in allen sieben ikk zentren in
afghanistan
10.000 orthesen diese schienen für
menschen die ihre lieder noch haben aber
dennoch behindert sind eine art lähmung
[Musik]
sie macht einen negativ abdruck für eine
orthese
dieser mann ist blind aber er kann
problemlos arbeiten
ich habe ihm gesagt vor sich fast
hättest du mich mit dem hammer
erschlagen
nadine ist seit 25 jahren hier und hat
sich bis zum direktor empor gearbeitet
ich bin nicht auf meine position stolz
oder darauf direktor dieses zentrums zu
sein
das ist mir egal aber wenn ich als
direktor menschen helfen kann dann macht
mich das glücklich und stolz
[Musik]
wir sind zurück im abgelegenen dorf
dessen namen wir nicht nennen dürfen
in der zwischenzeit hat abraham doblo
den kommandanten der lng rias getroffen
hier in dieser schule filmen durften wir
nicht
es ist schwierig ihn zu finden
es war das erste mal dass wir so direkt
mit ihm sprechen
ich habe schon mit einem der run wohnen
kommandanten gesprochen aber nicht mit
diesem es war sehr positiv und entspannt
und ich konnte meine bedenken über die
humanitäre situation äußern
ich konnte sogar anschuldigungen der
bevölkerung ansprechen die wir
dokumentiert haben allerdings ins all
ihren vorwurf der verletzung des
humanitären völkerrechts nicht direkt am
tag
er hat aber versichert mir die antwort
seiner vorgesetzten zu überbringen
überraschend billigen einige
ehrenmitglieder ein sie im dschungel
anonymisiert zu filmen
die elenden ist auf der liste der
terrororganisationen der europäischen
union
die letzten entführungen geschah nur
zwei monate vor unserem dreht als die
rebellen im dschungel verschwinden atmen
wir erleichtert auf
[Musik]
ist der fall er hat den ersten
arbeitstag hinter sich
ihre wohnung die das ikk für die
angestellten bietet teilt sie mit einer
arbeitskollegin
das ist nun also eine typische koschere
küche
es gibt alles zweimal eine seite ist für
das fleisch und eine für den milch wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe
ich bin keine expertin in jüdischen
belangen
vielleicht ist es nicht ganz richtig
aber es geht jedenfalls alles zweimal
[Musik]
vom balkon aus sieht man am ende der
straße sogar das meer das ist schön
als lausannerin bin ich es gewohnt vom
balkon aus den see zu sehen
jetzt ist es dass mehr
weil sie morgen ihren ersten
gefängnisbesuch macht büffelt sie noch
etwas arabisch gelernt hat sie es im
libanon aber das vokabular dass sie
morgen benötigt ist spezifisch ich habe
realisiert dass ich nicht weiß wie man
handschellen auf arabisch sagt ob sie zu
eng sind und so jetzt mache ich mir eine
liste mit möglichen redewendungen
aber sie sollten nicht zu starr sein
salz bringt es auch nicht ich möchte
einfach ein paar ansatzpunkte haben dann
ist es einfacher etwas abzuleiten wenn
ich vor ort bin
[Musik]
zurück im kinderheim in goma 3000 kinder
leben hier
sein
es gibt eine hohe sterblichkeit der
mütter im wochenbett bis zu 20 prozent
wenn die familie nicht für die kinder
sorgen kann werden sie hierher gebracht
wir kümmern uns um sie ein zwei jahre
dann versuchen wir sie bei angehörigen
unter zu bringen
wir helfen auch bei der suche nach den
familien
[Musik]
hier hält maurer das jüngste waisenkind
dem abend
ja das ist valerie
was sie jetzt anders bremerhaven
sie produzierten heimat ist einfach auf
die straße gestellt wurden und nach
worden
jetzt fehlen verlängerung bevor ich es
eigentlich nicht
[Musik]
das zentrum don bosco wird von vielen
verschiedenen hilfsorganisationen
unterstützt das ikk hat hier ein eigenes
programm für kinder die ihre familien
auf der flucht verloren haben
in einer suppenküche werden
unterernährte kinder aufgepäppelt viele
sind auch hiv-positiv
sie kommen vier mal die woche und
erhalten diese getreide suppe
[Musik]
diplomatisch tätig ist dass die
erlebniswelt ein ersatz her
als ich jünger wäre ja eigentlich nicht
deprimierend wenn man sagt ich genau
geschieht wirklich passt daher rufe wie
tod und die finger weil man so viel über
haufen und sophia bedürfnis hey ich
eigentlich nicht deprimierend dass ich
mehr mutigen nomads machen da diese
region wird ziemlich vernachlässigt um
nicht zu sagen vergessen wegen des
krieges oder wegen problemen der
internationalen politik vielleicht oder
wegen verträgen die uns ignorieren
die region hier ist extrem reich aber
die bevölkerung die leer aus
[Musik]
der kleine christian ist im ihk
präsidenten den ganzen tag gefolgt als
ob er sagen wollte
vergesst uns nicht und vielleicht trägt
maurers besuch im kongo ein wenig dazu
überreden
auch das gehört zu seiner arbeit als
präsident
[Musik]
im orthopädie zentrum in kabul ist die
neue prothese von allah mohammad nach
sechs tagen und mehreren anpassungen
fertig guten tag geht es gut danke
[Musik]
das braucht
jetzt kannst du deine hosen runter
rollen
jetzt bist du ganz neu
die neue prothese passt
[Musik]
wenn er die hosen über der prothese
trägt sieht man nicht dass er amputiert
ist jetzt probiert er noch ein wenig zu
sehen ob die prothese wirklich passt
doch sie nirgends drückt anschließend
wird er ohne probleme gehen können
der direktor vielen dank und auf
wiedersehen
gesund bleiben kann ich noch etwas für
sie tun das wichtigste ist dass du
richtig gut gehen kannst
die neue prothese bedeutet für aller
mohammad viel er kann sich besser
bewegen und findet so vielleicht eine
arbeit um seine familie zu unterstützen
[Musik]
nach dem treffen mit dem
rebellenkommandanten will abraham tobago
auch noch mit den einwohnern des dorfes
sprechen
sie werden nicht nur von rebellen
sondern auch von kriminellen banden
beträgt habt ihr schon leute vom ikk
gesehen
das erste mal dass ikea ist eine
humanitäre organisation
wie viele personen leben hier
wir sind 200 personen 33 familien 33
familien viele kinder die bewaffneten
sind ein heikles thema bleiben die hier
über nacht
ich möchte jetzt nicht darüber sprechen
wenn alle hier sind aber ich möchte
wissen wie sie mit ihrem leben
sie können auch einzeln mit uns sprechen
aber nur wenn sie möchten gut sprechen
wir später darüber
es ist wichtig die indios haben noch
ganz andere probleme als die anwesenheit
der rebellen bei geburten oder
krankheiten sind sie ganz auf sich
gestellt
die größten probleme gibt es bei der
gesundheit und ernährung ein arzt kommt
selten
ist weit weg und es gibt kein motorboot
um zug zu fahren
die einwohner gehören zu den ärmsten der
welt und das wenige das sie haben wird
ihnen nicht selten von herum streifenden
kriminellen gestohlen
und doch vielleicht helfen abrahams
gespräche mit rebellen und banken ihre
situation zu verbessern
[Musik]
wir sind auf der rückfahrt vom
befragungs zentrum key schon nach tel
aviv vorn und stéphanie haben
inhaftierte palästinenser besucht
israelische behörden gewähren medien
dort kaum je zutritt
[Musik]
am morgen machte wenn die ersten drei
interviews
ich hörte nur zu und machte während der
registrierungen notizen
am nachmittag machte ich mein erstes ich
realisierte welche ausdrücke ich noch
nicht beherrschte und vielleicht werde
ich unterricht bei einem
palästinensischen freund nehmen um so
auch die palästinensischen dialekt
begriffe für bestimmte antworten und
ausdrücke zu haben
und ich möchte auch die allgemeinen
frage gut ausformuliert bei mir haben
dann ist es stressfreier aber alles in
allem lief es gut
es war eine gute erfahrung und ich freue
mich mehr besucher zu machen und mehr
menschen zu treffen
jetzt wartet viel administration auf die
beiden
jeder fall wird dokumentiert bonn
richtet die sala maz die größe der
gefangenen an deren familien weiter möge
allah ihnen gesundheit und kraft geben
kann ich etwas ausrichten
das war die ehe
ich habe ihr gesagt dass es ihrem mann
gut geht
wir haben nachgefragt sie hat sich
bedankt so einfach kann es seien aber
gespräche noch lang sein wenn die
angehörigen mehr wissen wollen oder grob
werden
aber du wirst spüren was du sagen kannst
und was nicht
das mag ich nicht am telefon arabisch zu
sprechen
ja das ist schwierig du hast noch eine
andere nummer
ich hasse dich jetzt höre ich so ein
band in hebräisch auch entschuldigen
du musst die null wählen um rauszukommen
versuchst du mich noch nervöser zu
machen
ich bin stéphanie von michael k am 19
hat er die gerichtsverhandlung
wenn alles gut geht dort können sie ja
gott sie bis zum gerichtstermin gesund
machen geschafft sie wirkten froh und
erleichtert von ihrem sohn zu hören weil
er noch befragt wird dürfen sie nicht
sehen aber wir schon
er wurde vor mindestens 14 tagen
verhaftet sie hatten so lange keine
nachricht von ihm
ich bin froh vielleicht gehe ich jetzt
zu weit aber ich denke sie schlafen
heute nacht ein bisschen besser weil sie
wissen dass er am leben ist und dass ein
paar menschen ihn gesehen haben
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge bekommen wir doch
noch die seltene gelegenheit stefanie er
in ein gefängnis zu begleiten
[Musik]
in kolumbien wird abraham dobler aus
einem fest herausgerissen
eine handgranate fordert einen
schwerverletzten in kabul erhalten wir
ein blick in eine ganz besondere
schneiderei diese frauen waren nacho
dienst ehemalige patientinnen
in goma gelingt es dem ikk einen
vermissten sohn seiner familie
zurückzubringen
die freude ist groß
[Musik]